Oh
so Kevin Kelley the co-founder of Wired
magazine has this wonderful idea about
how the emergence of language was
actually the first singularity right in
other words the world on the other side
of that line after language emerged
would have been unimaginable to the
creature standing on the previous on the
other side of that line right try to
explain the nuances of
a Shakespearean sonnet to an ape are
simply unimaginable right this is
inconceivable we simply lacked the
wetware right so language what is
language Kevin Kelley says it's a tool
that allows the mind to know what its
thinked right it turned a fear or mind
into a tool that could now think with
purpose and deliberation right language
allowed us to create a virtual world in
our heads and pull the present forward
to meet that the ability to design to
envision to plan to Imagineer was the
natural consequence to the emergence of
language again a tool that allows the
mind to know what it's thinking right
language has to do with sentence before
language there was no self-awareness
there was no self-consciousness right
language came about as a kind of vortex
of self mirroring rightit's language and
self-awareness is is kind of like
plugging a video camera into the TV
aiming it at the team
and then soon be engulfed in infinity
write a recursive infinity loop that
gets formed and I don't I find that idea
to be astonishing really think of how it
transformed the mental operating system
right you can see why Kelley will call
it the first singularity language
you